Who doesn’t love a walk through a dark forest? The
sight of branches set against the low moonlight
looking like all manner of dark and twisted
claws reaching out of the night to grab at you.
Every step brings with it the snap of a broken
twig that practically echoes around you. Whenever
a breeze rustles the leaves on the trees, you feel
like something might just be following you, moving
through the forest towards you. It’s easy to get
lost in a forest at night, after all, that’s why
the children’s song warns us that “if you go down
to the woods today, you’d better not go alone.”
The image of a forest in the darkness has inspired
fear for generations, from fireside folktales
telling of wolves and monsters lurking among
the trees, to modern horror games about a tall,
faceless man in a suit stalking you through the
woods. And then, of course, there’s SCP-060,
otherwise known as the Infernal Occult Skeleton.
Now, despite its name, SCP-060 is, in actual fact,
a forest. Or at least, it’s a forest to begin
with. A picturesque grove of seventeen tall,
white oak trees, spread out across eight acres
of land in rural northeast Minnesota. It almost
looks like something out of a tourist brochure,
a beautiful stretch of forest sitting under
clear skies, well, during the daytime anyway.
If you ever find yourself hiking through a corner
of Minnesotan forest that isn’t in any of the
guidebooks, then tread carefully. You might just
stumble upon the demolished ruins of a house that
used to stand among the trees, out in seclusion.
And a word of advice to you if you happen across
this place, do not, under any circumstances,
stop walking for a smoke break.
Of course, thanks to the good folks at
the SCP Foundation, you’re unlikely to ever just
wander your way into SCP-060. More likely, they’ll
administer you with amnestics – the Foundation’s
patented memory-altering drugs – and send you on
your merry way, totally oblivious to the huge,
hard-to-miss greenhouses containing SCP-060.
Beyond those glass walls, you might have caught
glimpses of Foundation personnel watering the
trees, carefully tending to each SCP-060 specimen.
Maybe you saw them gathering up leaves and pruning
each tree individually, composting every part of
dead plant matter instead of leaving the white
oaks to grow freely. And perhaps you even
noticed that not one member of personnel
was carrying a lighter on their person, nor a
taser, or so much as a small box of matches,
nothing that can start a fire. Or rather,
you would remember seeing all that,
if the amnestics hadn’t already made you forget.
But what’s so special about these trees? Why would
the SCP Foundation go to the extent of housing
a collection of white oaks in greenhouses,
and meticulously oversee their growth? What
is it about these particular specimens that
make personnel so cautious about fire safety? And
why on earth is SCP-060, a collection of trees,
referred to by the nickname
‘the Infernal Occult Skeleton’?
Well, the answer to all those questions
becomes pretty apparent the moment any
of the SCP-060 oak trees catch fire, and
something comes hurtling out of the forest.
That something is known as SCP-060-Alpha.
Standing at just over two meters tall,
the entity takes the form of an adult human
skeleton. Much more than just a spooky,
scary collection of bones, SCP-060-Alpha is
fully animate, capable of moving of its own
accord without the aid of muscles or a nervous
system. Oh, and it also happens to be on fire.
Move aside Ghost Rider, SCP-060-Alpha is engulfed
from skull to toe bones in bright white flames,
burning at a temperature of approximately
fifteen-hundred degrees Celsius, or almost
three thousand degrees Fahrenheit. For reference,
that’s just shy of the melting point of iron,
and hot enough to grant a human being
a quick, but agonizingly painful death.
Granted after a few seconds of that heat your
nerve endings would be scalded, so maybe you
wouldn’t feel that much pain. But fifteen-hundred
Celsius is enough to burn the moisture right out
of your skin, melt your eyeballs, and generally
fry you to a crisp in a matter of minutes,
if not seconds. Good thing SCP-060-Alpha isn’t
known for being highly aggressive and hostile.
Oh, wait, it is? Ah, not good.
Upon manifestation, the burning skeleton will
attempt to do as much damage as possible,
and usually to whoever is closest. It can appear
at any time, and after as little as twenty grams
worth of one of the SCP-060 trees is burned.
As if being actively hostile and burning hot
enough to reshape metal wasn’t bad enough,
SCP-060-Alpha has also shown itself to be
fiercely intelligent. The entity seems to retain
knowledge whenever it manifests and has gained
a growing familiarity with the layout of the
Foundation site that contains the SCP-060 oaks.
The Infernal Occult Skeleton’s methods of attack
tend to include throwing its entire body at
flammable materials; however, it will avoid
causing any damage to specimens of SCP-060.
The skeletal entity can run at speeds of up
to fifty miles per hour, now that’s almost the
same speed as a gazelle. Just picturing anything
traveling towards you at that speed is horrifying,
let alone something heading straight for you
at gazelle levels of speed while also on fire!
It’s this combination of speed and heat that means
SCP-060-Alpha poses such a threat to anyone close
whenever it appears; if left unchecked,
the entity could easily cause colossal and
widespread forest fires and property damage.
Interestingly, any areas that SCP-060-Alpha
does burn with its flames, will start
to yield saplings of the SCP-060 oaks,
around six weeks after the fire has stopped. The
Foundation doesn’t allow these saplings to grow
to full size, and instead pulls them from the
ground and disposes of them, composting the
saplings to feed the other SCP-060 specimens.
Luckily, the biggest strength of SCP-060-Alpha,
its flames, also happens to be its greatest
weakness. It is possible to fight the fires
of the Infernal Occult Skeleton by dousing
it with water or any other materials capable
of dousing flames, whether it’s sand or
foam from a fire extinguisher. Of course,
this is a lot hotter and harder to put out than
any ordinary, smaller-scale fire, but despite
being a difficult task, it’s not impossible. About
five hundred liters of water should do the trick
if you’ve got a big enough bucket nearby.
After that, SCP-060-Alpha will be weakened,
gradually collapsing and turning into dust.
However, if another part of an SCP-060 tree is
burned and the entity reappears, it is believed
that this will be the same Infernal Occult
Skeleton, rather than a new version of the bone
burning being. So, we have a grove of oak trees
that manifest a flaming skeleton if they are ever
burned. Maybe that’s not the weirdest thing you’d
see in a Minnesotan forest, but wait, there’s
something else. Cast your mind back a few minutes,
and you’ll remember that we mentioned some ruins,
the remains of a demolished house that used to
stand secluded among the SCP-060 white oak trees.
Knowing that the Infernal Occult Skeleton can
appear from the oaks might make it
obvious what happened to this house,
but there’s still a story to be told here.
The house’s owner was a man by the name of
Johnathan Corhill. Now, Johnathan was something
of an odd man, considered a bit of an eccentric
to some. He preferred to spend his time in
solitude, alone with his own thoughts for company,
rather than mingling among the rest of the
world. Even his own family noticed that Mr.
Corhill was drifting away from them, becoming a
more bitter, nihilistic person in his old age,
and choosing isolation over human connection.
Now, sure, loneliness doesn’t hold much appeal
to everyone, but sometimes there are
people who just prefer being alone.
That might be what drew Johnathan Corhill to his
secluded little house in the forests of Minnesota,
somewhere no one would bother him.
For the most part, the rest of the Corhill
family adjusted to their eccentric relative’s
behavior. Johnathan would have rarely accepted
visitors to his house in the forest, but he still
kept in contact with those he’d been close with.
Most notably, he’d regularly share phone
calls with his brother, one Christopher
Corhill. That is... Until something seemed
to change unexpectedly, in the year 1996.
On one of their calls, Johnathan outright
told Christopher to never contact him again,
severing all ties with any remaining family
members and friends in the outside world.
Johnathan cut everyone off, living within his
own bubble where he could immerse himself in
his unusual interests. According to Christopher,
his brother had seemed otherwise normal up until
a certain phone conversation, but Johnathan had
become obsessed with the occult. Specifically,
he had embroiled himself in the history of the
Victorian-era, and certain supernatural practices
that had been undertaken in that time period.
Now whether Christopher honored his brother’s
wish to sever ties is unknown. A mail carrier
would visit Johnathan’s home in the woods not
long after their phone call. Maybe among the
envelopes, this courier was delivering what could
have been a letter from Christopher, or other
members of the Corhill family, begging their
estranged relative to come back to the world.
You see, even people who claim to prefer being
on their own sometimes need human interaction.
Talking to people, being in the presence of
friends and family, are hugely important factors
in maintaining a positive state of mental health.
But what happens when someone rejects that
entirely and instead becomes lost in their
obsessive study of the occult? Well, the
mail carrier was the first to find out.
Arriving at Johnathan Corhill’s woodland
house, the courier found the place looking
almost skeletal, a shell of the building that had
once stood in the forest. According to the locals,
the carrier had been sent to deliver a notice to
Mr Corhill, explaining that his house was being
foreclosed. But it seemed someone, or something,
had beaten them to it. A fire had spread from the
house’s fireplace, quickly engulfing the entire
structure, presumably with Johnathan still inside.
It wasn’t until later that very same year
that Johnathan Corhill was officially
reported as a missing person case with local
authorities. Any search that was undertaken
in an attempt to find him uncovered
next to no evidence of his whereabouts.
To this day, nobody knows for certain if
Johnathan Corhill is dead or alive, his
whereabouts are unknown. On the surface, it might
be easy to make the assumption that the Infernal
Occult Skeleton reduced the reclusive old man to
nothing more than a cinder. It definitely seems
plausible that Johnathan, collecting firewood to
keep himself warm in his isolation, accidentally
chopped down part of an SCP-060 oak, put it in his
fireplace, and called forth the vengeful flaming
bones. But perhaps we shouldn’t be so certain.
After all, Corhill’s house wasn’t entirely burned
down, despite the entity normally trying to cause
as much damage as possible whenever it appears.
And on top of that, no human remains were found
in the house. And the skeleton of SCP-060-Alpha
had to have come from somewhere, right?
SCP-060 offers a few warnings, and not just
about the dangers of traveling through the forest
alone. The appearance of the flaming skeleton
whenever the SCP-060 white oaks are burned
could serve as a reminder that we need to be
vigilant in protecting the forests of this world.
Trees are one of our few sustainable resources,
but for every one we cut down or that catches
fire, it takes years to regrow a replacement.
And perhaps the third and final warning
of the Infernal Occult Skeleton is simply:
don’t play with matches, especially around
trees. Otherwise, you might get burned.
Now go check out “The Plane That Never Was
SCP-787” and “SCP 1440 - The Old Man That
Kills All Living Things He Touches”
for more morbidly fascinating SCPs!